Sonic the Hedgehog is off to the races.
After a troubled production history that involved
a complete redesign of the title character
due to the first trailer giving fans nightmares,
the first live-action vehicle for the speedy
blue hedgehog from the iconic Sega video game
series is here.
The general critical consensus: not too shabby.
Sonic famously had its release date pushed
back from late last year due to the redesign,
which became necessary after fans took to
social media in droves to express their bewilderment,
disappointment, and abject terror at Sonic's
weird eyes, ripped thighs, and bizarrely human
teeth.
Fortunately for the filmmakers, the VFX shots
featuring Sonic in the trailer were the only
ones that had been finished, so it wasn't
a complete overhaul; studio Paramount had
to shell out a fair amount of dough to make
it happen, though, so the fact that critics
are so far pleased with Sonic has got to be
a relief for the studio's brass.
"They pulled out all my teeth!
It's perfect!"
The movie is Certified Fresh on Rotten Tomatoes,
and the positive notices generally agree that
while Sonic is far from perfect, it's a breezy
good time which benefits from a quick pace,
which is, really, only fitting.
"How are you not dead?"
"I have no idea."
It's not even necessary to be a fan of the
video game series to enjoy Sonic, as noted
by Johnny Oleksinski of the New York Post,
who wrote,
"The movie is a lot better than it deserves
to be.
You'll actually care about what happens to
the prickly blue dude, even if you never cared
about getting to zone seven...Sonic the Hedgehog
is very much in conversation with Pokémon:
Detective Pikachu."
A fair number of critics, such as the Washington
Post's Kristen Page-Kirby, seemed genuinely
shocked to be turning in a positive review.
The headline of her review contained a double-take,
reading, quote, "Sonic the Hedgehog is sweet,
funny, and smart.
Wait, what?"
The author praised Sonic as:
"Quippy without being mean, and sweet without
being sappy, making [it] a trip that's well
worth taking."
In general, the flick's positive reviews found
it to be a fun, family-friendly, action-packed
ride with a distinct '90s vibe.
The Weekend Warrior's Edward Douglas put it
like this:
"Is it possible that Sonic the Hedgehog is
the first thoroughly entertaining movie of
the year?
Yes, indeedy."
Negative reviews, meanwhile, found Sonic the
Hedgehog to be just mediocre.
Those who disagreed with the majority found
Sonic to be a halfhearted effort, not to mention
derivative of better films, such as E.T.,
and devoid of a unique sense of humor.
Referring to Sonic's infamous original design,
A.A.
Dowd of The A.V.
Club wrote,
"[When Sonic] opens his mouth...you maybe
wish those ghastly teeth were still there,
if only to distract from the lazy wisecracks,
pop culture references, and earnest clichés
that come flooding out...It's that kind of
movie: a nattering chore of a 'family' comedy
that feels written by committee and directed
by an indifferent machine."
Some negative notices at least conceded that
kids, as always, will probably be into Sonic,
even if it may leave their parents eyeing
the exit sign.
USA Today's Brian Truitt wrote,
"The film is fine, familiar fare for gamers
and children.
Sonic sprints, [Jim] Carrey mugs, but the
creative juices run out quickly."
In some critics, though, the flick simply
engendered outright hostility.
Evan Dossey of Midwest Film Journal wrote,
"It's been a long road for Sonic the Hedgehog
to the silver screen, considering it's a 30-year
old intellectual property that hasn't been
relevant for two decades.
A long, crazy, talent-sinking road that leads
to nowhere...Sonic the Hedgehog joins an endless
stream of attempted IP resurrections destined
to litter the bottom of the box office, forgotten
until their inevitable reboot or re-quel."
Regardless of whether or not the movie was
their cup of tea, critics agreed near-unanimously
on one thing: Jim Carrey turns in an unrestrained,
manic performance, the likes of which we haven't
seen for decades.
"Oh!
Give me a big!
Fat!
Break!"
In a positive review, Total Film's Jordan
Farley called Carrey's performance "preposterous,"
adding that adults in the audience would find
it to be, quote, "an enjoyable shot of nostalgia."
Travis Hopson of Punch Drunk Critics wrote,
"Whatever message the movie might have is
secondary to Carrey who dominates literally
every moment he's on screen, giving such an
exaggerated, wacky performance it makes Fire
Marshall Bill look positively tame."
In other words, Sonic the Hedgehog looks like
a heck of a lot of fun, perhaps surprisingly.
If nothing else, it deserves to be remembered
as a product of that time when fans chimed
in with their two cents on social media about
how a film could be made better, and the filmmakers
actually listened.
Regardless of how you may feel about Sonic,
that in itself is a minor miracle.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.